but you are about to hear is the
majority of a conversation that I had
with Jeremy Lee Quinn who was the only
National reporter on the ground in the
Lahaina area in the week after the fires
as I understand it
it was an excellent conversation
unfortunately it was marred by technical
difficulties that caused the audio on
Jeremy's side not to be recorded for the
first 20 minutes or so so the
conversation will start abruptly
mid-stream I think it is still well
worth a listen it is a Viewpoint that
you likely have not heard and frankly
his perspective changed my opinion of
what likely happened in Lahaina quite
substantially so I hope that you will
give it a listen I apologize for the
technical failure and I apologize to
Jeremy who has done heroic work in
unearthing the stories surrounding this
terrible disaster
hey folks welcome to a very special LIVE
edition of the Dark Horse podcast with
Jeremy Lee Quinn who is a
photojournalist he is also a broadcaster
working with a local affiliate in Hawaii
Jeremy Lee Quinn welcome to Darkhorse
yeah very good to see you and I should
mention that you have been a guest on
Dark Horse I believe twice before
which brings us to an odd fact of the
story which I think has no relevance
here but uh you are very frequently at
the epicenter of major historical events
in the other cases I know of it's
because you have deliberately brought
yourself there
um knowing that things were occurring
and that journalism needed to occur
uh in this case it seems like you've
been working in Hawaii for the last two
years and the fire or fires in Maui the
fire in Lahaina happened and you found
your way into that story because it
needed to be reported
the chaos
that has come with the response is
indicative of only that well and and you
can imagine in the circumstance that
unfolded right you've got fires
springing up people in charge of dealing
with fires a don't know how many there
actually are they know about the fires
that are reported they don't know about
what fires they may be about to be
surprised with they have to divide
resources across these things it is
quite likely to my way of thinking that
they would have divided resources in
ways that might not actually be
defensible in other words if you have
wealthy people's land threatened and
other people's land threatened and they
make a decision to try to preserve the
uh the wealthy folks uh homes that's not
defensible as far as I'm concerned but
right it's not something that would
surprise me if it had happened and
therefore it would create a reluctance
to just simply open the books and
explain how everything occur third
but there are uh confounders here
because remember we're dealing within a
Thousand Acre uh fire over in up country
the estate country as I described it
it's a thousand acres how big is the
flare-up you know is it even a couple
acres so you know yes fire moves very
fast when it's hit by 65 mile an hour
wind gusts
extremely dry conditions Maui I have
always lamented how especially on that
side it is extremely dry
um this island
um it can be especially during the
summer time and uh it reminds me you
know I'm from California and so it
reminds me of the driest conditions that
I have grown up with in California
wildfires that uh quite frankly I was
very happy being away from uh in my
career I uh you know Tahoe fired just
all kinds of different fires that I've
had to to be at um you know so there is
that can and founder which is they put
their resources on the bigger fire not
necessarily the fire with the richest
people
um so uh now that that said I am the one
who has been grilling the county and
they would they would not call on me and
at the first press conference because
I'm a pain in the ass and I issued my
questions to every agency saying tell me
the time stamp that the emergency
evacuation order was given if they were
to truthfully answer that the evidence
that I see points that the timestamp of
the emergency order was 6 40 in the
morning and then at 9 00 a.m it was
declared 100 contained therefore I have
seen no evidence and I'm going to get a
chance to ask the mayor this directly uh
coming up very soon I've seen no
evidence that a second PM afternoon
order was ever issued and the Facebook
posts characterize the people people as
self-evacuating evacuating on their own
it never says that an order is given
already by the four o'clock and five
o'clock hours Lahaina is being choked by
the this enormous Cloud I get more video
in day by day
um and and it it quickly just succumbs
to being a Inferno okay
so I would say I I don't I don't have
expertise in firefighting I like you I'm
a Californian and so I've been through
many fire seasons and watched things
done well done badly and everything in
between
but there is a question of course as to
whether or not to prioritize the biggest
fire whether to prioritize the fire
that's closest to the densest population
those are tricky calculations and in a
context where you have
these tremendously powerful winds you
have emergencies springing up in various
places and as you point out you have
these natural bottlenecks that come from
the fact that there aren't very many
ways in and out and so it is easy to
imagine
that small amounts of incompetence turn
into calamities very easily with the fog
of not war here but the fog of an
ongoing emergent disaster
so that could that has the potential to
explain a lot there is also the oh go
ahead
I can explain a little bit from my point
of view I only know what I've seen who
I've talked to
on Thursday in the evening
I'm sorry I gotta back up to August 8th
Tuesday so this is the the hours of the
fire between 4 and 6 p.m where Lahaina
essentially is consumed I'm on the big
island in a district called North Kahala
just north of kona I will post some
video of I just found my outtakes as it
were where I'm doing I'm shooting my
stand-ups as we call it where your
reporter is just standing up now I'm a
one-man operation my camera is in the
SUV for the affiliate that I work with
on a tripod inside the SUV shooting
through the window and I'm speaking
through a wireless mic that's because it
wouldn't last a second if it were
outside on on the sticks I am recording
and I'm being just blown about and at
times I physically moved by these winds
if you open a door and the wind catches
it your your car door can go off it
tinges you can feel that happening what
happens to me is I'm supposed to do my 6
p.m live shot and I see behind me
there's this stump that's burnt out I
picked a place that had been mopped up
already with a burnt out melted Ranch
fence behind me because it looked great
and I'm a reporter in a you know I I
framed it for the drama so I'm looking
behind me and there's this stump that's
every time that it's hit with a wind
gust it starts glowing it's it's black
and then it's glowing I look back again
and then I see Embers I look back a
third time and all of a sudden the grass
line a dry grass line that shoots you
know back several yards is on fire and
it's smoking and it's right behind me I
tell them I get the call you know okay
we're gonna have you in three minutes no
you're not gonna have me in three
minutes I'm shutting down the shot and
uh not just for my safety I have to find
somebody that is what was on my mind I
went to the last point in that
subdivision known as Kohala Ranch where
I had seen a fire engine and my heart
dropped because it was gone it was not
there now I am navigating just one
Street in a subdivision of three Ranch
blocks trying to find somebody I see a
pickup truck I I hail the guy down I say
you know the place where the melted
fence you guys got a flare there's a
flare-up he thanks me profusely he's the
ranch manager he's on a walkie-talkie he
radio is the fire department
keep in mind I have zero bars through
through this while I'm driving not
because of the fire necessary of cell
towers being down which we know is the
case in West Maui but just because it's
the big island and we have remote areas
where you do you do not have reception
and I would imagine there are places in
West Maui where reception is limited as
well
Okay so
I I hear a recipe for disaster
I hear a recipe for
theorizing about nefarious intent
that unfortunately maps onto that
disaster landscape but there are things
I've also heard reported that aren't
accounted for here so for example in the
aftermath of the fire the refusal to
distribute materials that were donated
that were supposed to be going to people
who were suffering the under counting of
bodies where individual firefighters saw
more bodies than were being accounted
for by the entire uh recovery effort
um what can you say about why it is that
there's the appearance of
of a cover-up and of a pretend uh rescue
operation where materials are simply
never making it to the people who need
them
um so so let me address the second one
materials are making it to the people
who need them there are seven
distribution sites pods as they're
called and each one is not set up by the
government but they are set up by
individual communities all of which have
their own character to them several of
them are led by the indigenous native
Hawaiian community and I have ties to
the sovereignty movement who
um are you know believe in
sustainability for the Hawaiian people
and uh are doing everything that they
can to uh take care of community but
that is not exclusionary that is not
exclusionary to others who may not be of
that ancestry
um there are there are it is
um there are I would say four sites that
are like that in different Parks but
again anybody is welcome to that Aid
also there's a firefighter uh site which
uh retired firefighters and firefighters
from all over the islands came and
that's in nepili Plaza so that has a
little more of a
um establishment vibe to it I guess you
could say but even the firefighters that
I interviewed there said nobody's really
in charge here this is all volunteers
then there was a what I used to call the
county site and even that site everybody
says everybody's a volunteer here the
only affiliation was the guy who was on
point his wife worked for the county but
there was no sort of official
uh government effort that was underway
the people had to mobilize and do what
they had to do to get these Goods that
they knew were coming to them and uh yes
I do I do get reports that you know the
coast guard told people they couldn't go
a certain way uh by the island of Lanai
which is that neighboring Island that's
owned by that you know billionaire and
so forth and so they were told they
couldn't go that direction there are
different you know you anecdotes but for
the most part you should know this all
seven of these pods are very well
stocked right now with goods and they
are distributed them when you are in
West Maui people walk up to you and ask
you if you've eaten if you would like
you know and for days I I declined of
course and and uh had my own you know
way of of eating brought food with me
but but
um people are provided for it's not a
humanitarian crisis in that sense people
have stepped up and are doing what
government failed to do okay okay but uh
FEMA the Red Cross is it Distributing
materials as you would expect are they I
I wouldn't say I wouldn't say FEMA but
the Red Cross I have seen them uh in the
hotels they are Distributing uh Aid they
are also trying to get people registered
which is a big part of it so that they
can be you know reimbursed and can be so
they are on the ground FEMA has a public
relations specialist who I interviewed
and my questions was what what do you do
about the widespread public distrust and
all of these anecdotes about what you're
here for FEMA has a search and rescue
squad that they're they are primarily in
the burn Zone from what I have seen they
are primarily
um
mobilized there and are providing
cadaver dogs the question that you asked
first transparency one of my pieces uh
was a woman in a hotel saying tell us
tell us the truth we've already lived it
we how much that's what someone else
said how much worse can it get we've
already lived it uh another a principle
at a school said to me this is inhumane
to keep us in the dark like this because
remember everybody in West Maui for the
over a period of the week was
disconnected communication wise I said I
would go to these pods and say what do
you need and this they said information
we you know yes there are there are
nuances of we need baby formula we don't
need clothes we have way too much
clothes we we need this one thing we
need feminine products you know yes
there are the the lists of of yes we
need more of this and we need less of
this and those those pods are
communicating and trading so to speak so
people get things at the Pod that they
they don't have that another pod might
have more of but the number one
commodity that was lacking was
information people were disconnected
they didn't know what had happened in a
huge part of healing is understanding
what has happened to you and I think
when it comes I asked my dad once about
conspiracy theories my dad is uh uh it
was he's now a retired Public Health
doctor and uh and I'm interesting
interested in your take on this that
that what what is it in our ancestry
that perhaps
is a survival skill to be paranoid and
distrustful is it survival skill when
something
so disastrous this hat like this happens
that that we jump towards certain
defenses so as to ensure that this will
not happen again and there are one of
two options you know I posted
um evidence pointing to failure
you know and not conspiracy but those
are the two options really is it
something that was planned or is it
something an immense seismic failure
that all of us you know are are still
stunned and traumatized by well I want
to answer your question I know I said
that there were two options there are
really three and so far I'm compelled
that it's the third which we'll come
back to in a second but you asked me why
it is that we humans are prone to
um
to look for nefarious motives and
collusion in
conditions where there's terrible
misfortune
and I would say
there are two things one in the absence
of a properly functioning civilization
there's an awful lot of collusion so it
makes sense to be actively aware of it
because
more often than not it is present
in the functioning
civilization that is not the case
because those who would conspire against
the Public's interest cannot profit by
doing so and so collusion can become
rare
the problem is we are living in an era
where capture has disrupted all of the
things that would allow us to figure out
what's taking place and has enabled
those with the power to uh to collude
well to transfer well-being from other
people to themselves
so especially having just been through
coveted Madness and watching collusion
at so many different levels
simultaneously it's hard not to feel
that those forces are liable to be
lurking behind any great Misfortune and
believe me if they were in this scenario
I wouldn't be shy about contemplating it
I think there are people just plain cold
enough to inflict this much misery if it
benefited them sufficiently and they
thought they could get away with it I
don't put it past them what I do put it
past them is to be able to orchestrate
this as a result of an opportunity
presented by a hurricane in such a way
that it would both be so devastating
and uh difficult to establish so I am
open to the possibility that something
like that has happened but I'm skeptical
that it it did and the reason
this this brings us back to category
three
somebody could have planned a disaster
that they would have Unleashed upon the
discovery that nature was going to give
them a an opportunity to cover it up
that's the full collusion explanation
which I so far have no reason to believe
is accurate
then there's the pure incompetence uh
explanation which frankly
could explain an awful lot of what I've
heard just by virtue of the fact that
it's very hard to manage a disaster like
this well and it's very easy to Monday
Morning Quarterback the errors and the
errors were compounded by people
uh making bad calls and fearing that
they would be exposed or who knows what
but the third possibility which I think
is so far what I think is most likely
is you had an organic disaster that will
predictably have had there will be
somebody who was warning that Lahaina
was a Tinder Box and that all it was
going to take was the wrong set of
weather circumstances and you know down
power lines to unleash a firestorm that
wouldn't be controllable they will have
been ignored that's almost always true
in the cases that you have a disaster
like this where somebody saw the
potential and it was much easier to
ignore them than listen to them but then
the thing that really makes this
difficult to sort out is the fact that
there clearly are opportunists who live
by this Mantra never let a good
um what do they say disaster anyways
crisis go to waste and we obviously have
people uh doing land speculation which
is absolutely ghastly in light of the
disaster that has unfolded but it's
obviously happening that speaks to a
willingness
to find a fortune in the uh the
tragedies of other people so when you
see that when you see people willing to
look at this through those that that
cold lens willing to take advantage of
this opportunity and you wonder well
what else would they have been willing
to do the fact is I think
it would be lovely if we could take off
the table that this was this was an evil
beyond what humans would have uh have
endeavored to to create and that's just
simply not true the willingness to do it
is probably something we can establish
but the opportunity to do it isn't so
clear
but this land is ruined there's no
there's no incentive it's it's it's a
com it's a complete loss it's it's a
town that had so much history and was so
vibrant and it's just gone it's it's
leveled there's and it will take decades
until it's something else uh again it's
there's just I don't see any logic in
that and it hasn't been beneficial for
me to entertain any any kind of you know
as I said I get these texts all the time
but you cannot fake this level of
incompetence that's the other thing you
know when it came to this tsunami
warning system the woman that I
interviewed in the hotel the evacue she
said we have these go off every month
and anybody who's lived on Oahu or the
big island or uh Maui knows that these
these systems go on all the time the
director who is now resigned his
explanation was that would be an
indication to seek Higher Ground
and he didn't want people per the
protocol to be seeking Higher Ground and
going towards the fire now he was
disconnected to the reality of the cell
phone videos what we see in the videos
which is a big dark black cloud hovering
over Lahaina it was very obvious where
the fire was and where you needed to
move away from so when I presented his
rationale to the evacuees to the
survivors they said we knew where we
needed to go away from the fire that was
about to Reign Terror essentially and
destroy all of Lahaina it was obvious
where they needed to go but what those
Sirens would have done was woken people
up and quickly mobilized people uh much
sooner in the 4 pm hour if those Sirens
Sirens were off people wouldn't have
been standing in line it's Safeway or in
an orderly manner wait to pay for you
know not wanting to loot but people were
waiting in line at Safeway to pay for
water because they knew they needed to
stock up on water and goods because they
would be in an evacuate situation so
those Sirens would have done a lot I
believe also text alerts wouldn't have
come in then but they would have come in
in the aftermath and they would have
come in uh in the days after when all of
West Maui was left on its own in the
dark for for a week so so the missteps
in the incompetence that I have
witnessed and that I have challenged is
too real to be faked in my opinion
yeah I I I hear you loud and clear and
you know let's take that that uh
decision not to fire off the tsunami
warning right
on the one hand I understand what the
residents are saying which is we're not
dumb the evidence was clear if you'd
fired that warning we would have
properly interpreted on the other hand
as the person making the decision to to
set off the alarm or not you can imagine
the terror of
that there is you know I as I understand
from you that there was some discussion
on for example the web page associated
with the tsunami warning that the
warning could be used in the case of a
fire it didn't inherently mean tsunami
but to a population that lives in the
shadow of the ever-present threat of a
tsunami as the Hawaiian Coastal
population does
the idea of setting off a a one meaning
alarm
in which there is an urgency to move to
Higher Ground I could imagine fearing
sending people to their deaths and I can
imagine that having been an incorrect
fear but nonetheless it is an
understandable one from the point of
view of the person making the decision
to do it so you know you you could there
there isn't a good answer there there
isn't a good answer to a lot of these
things because what you're talking about
is a somebody making a call remotely
likely likely this emergency office you
know manager was closer to the other
fire that we were talking about up
country or Kula as it's known which had
you know over a thousand acres burning
so if he's closer to that fire and he
isn't in Lahaina then he does not see
the the smoke because the way Maui is
situated you know that's not visible
from uh where I am well now where
anybody is because that's up you know
and the twisting Highway and and uh 40
minutes drive or so away so he does not
know necessarily and he's not seeing
what people are ground nursing and the
people on the ground cannot tell him
what they're seeing because all cell
communication is down and has been since
the late morning even
so I wanna
make sure to cover a couple things
before you have to go yes one is
uh
so we've talked about the distribution
of goods which you're saying is better
than we on the outside necessarily have
reason to understand yes it's getting
there the stuff is getting there good
news uh from the point of view of the
Under reporting of deaths
you I believe have alluded to the
possibility that that frankly it's an
excuse that worries me because it is
always used to cover up uh Dirty Deeds
which is that we can't afford to tell
the public what's actually going on
because they will be panicked or
saddened or disheartened or whatever
it's always nonsense and it's often used
in part of a cover-up but in your case
you're saying you hear people who are
making the wrong judgment but you
believe they are making it earnestly
they don't want to make life worse for
people who've just been through hell the
governor's quote at the first press
conference which was the Thursday after
the fire two days after is we do not
want those in the shelters to lose all
hope they were they knew more than we
knew and it it was obvious that they
were going to take what he called a
conservative approach in disseminating
the bad news uh this is a this is a
doctor also a physician who is our
governor who uh you know who I don't
have anything against and I pressed him
on the access issue
um on the at the tour we the local media
was taken through a walk through a walk
through of Front Street and the
destruction and I and I pressed about
the access issue
um I don't see any malfeasance but I see
um is there possible that that the
numbers are throttled
yes that's possible let me tell you
where we are when we reached a hundred
deaths we were at 25 of the affected
Zone surveyed so that means if we're
just going on proportion that that would
get us to you know 400 at some point
um the
the
yes people are wondering if it's a lot
more just because of the sheer
catastrophe of what and the chaos of the
evacuation uh people are especially
concerned about children in the elderly
it is true that that school was canceled
for the day because of the morning fire
so
when it comes to who is being identified
I'm sure it is an arduous process
I think that without you know if you're
if you're the governor if you're if you
have to communicate the scope of what
this is this is what the woman in my
piece that I posted said tell us don't
you know tell us we're gonna find out
eventually we are you can't hide things
like this so if it is upward of you know
of what at first glance they're willing
to admit I would hope that they would
reconsider and tell us is this going to
be a slow painful process that much is
clear because from the Thursday in which
this presser was
um
you know we had the opportunity to first
ask questions it has been a very long
week and one in which the Press was
essentially excluded from the effective
area and I only got in by my own share
you know persistence
um
so I don't I will go one step further
they just don't have the right to hold
back the information they just don't
have the right they have to tell you
even even if it will dishearten people
that's my feeling the power to not tell
people things will be abused every time
and I I I'm completely out of patience
with that excuse
um so I I yeah I agree that people need
to know irrespective of how awful the
news may be and we were told that not to
be to realize this was a sensitive time
and and this kind of thing that this is
traumatic that yes I do understand that
I am not uh unsympathetic you know all
of us reporters have broken down just
completely broken down at one time or
another and seeing it and seeing what
we're seeing I mean it is just complete
destruction and death and
and I've never seen anything like it um
in my in my career and
and all of us are trying to hold it
together but we we need to at the same
time confront and acknowledge the scope
of this and I think that's been
happening but the way that the first
week was handled in which West Maui was
essentially sequestered and cut off and
um
um you know in isolation it was not it
was unkind and
the idea that yes there were issues when
they tried to open up on the Friday
after so three days after people went
straight for the burn Zone and wanted to
see and we were living in this you know
selfie culture where everybody wanted
that picture and to get it out first and
I think that was a part of it plus you
have to talk about the respect for the
indigenous people for the Hawaiian
people
I broke out and got there and the first
person I talked to is a young man named
and he was doing Instagram videos and he
met me and I did a couple I did a
long-form interview with him and his
message was do not sell your land to the
community we will get through this we
will pull together do not sell your land
and do not sell your land to Outsiders
to Outsiders yes do not sell your land
to Outsiders to anyone outside and the
in the clip that I I uh a short clip
went viral and was seen over three
million times and and I I talked to the
people who are feeling it and who wanted
to be heard and they were banding
together and so there is a lot of
optimism and there is a whole lot of
fight and there's a whole lot of
strength that's coming out of West Maui
right now and
um you know so don't get sidetracked by
all the other stuff everything
um the community is working hard they
are coming together they're showing each
other so much Aloha
um we are getting the the the shipment
since the the provisions they were
arriving to all of those uh drop sites
you know and I was feeling it and I I
was pitching and you know a lot I wasn't
worried my collared professional shirt
anymore because I was in a you know a
shirt in which I could lend a hand and
work too if you were there you were a
part of it you were feeling it and
that's what what community stepped in
where government was missing in action
and so the story
the stuff I think of conspiracies is a
natural human response to make sense of
the unexplainable
um to protect ourselves in some ways but
there's a bigger story here
um with I think a less cartoonish
villain which is our own inability to
accept things and to admit our faults
our our mistakes our missteps I mean
imagine being the person who made the
wrong call on that day and what they're
living with right now you know so it's
there's a bigger story that's that's
more human and that doesn't have a
cartoonish villain but has people who
are are working hard who are banding
together and a heart who are surviving
and uh it's an inspiring story and it
will be told all right that's uh I think
an excellent
uh summation uh and I I'm tempted to
leave it there but I want to make sure
to cover these other two things because
I think they are important
the story that people were trapped on
Front Street that the police themselves
were forbidding people to leave and that
this caused many to burn alive in alive
in their cars
um
has a very ominous ring
I will say go go ahead yeah I don't I
don't have a lot of time so I'll dive
right into it I just addressed this this
morning I met with several people who
were there so I got and what it all
comes down is to the logistical
understanding of Lahaina town okay
remember I I characterized West Valley
like this Lahaina is here you go on the
highway right to Lahaina you would the
highway would technically continue into
Lahaina and through Lahaina but there's
a bypass there's what for all practical
purposes what we call a highway that
goes around behind a couple Lahaina
Bypass that's where the fire remember
the brush fires were up here and they
jumped the bypass at 3 30 PM according
to Maui County's alerts
um now that bypass would be the only way
not the only way so if you're at where
Front Street ends and those people are
fleeing North Front Street goes to the
highway The Front Street in the in the
highway are parallel the highway that
goes through town right then Front
Street keeps going and then eventually
meets up with the highway up here and
then you go to those Northern
Communities that I were talking to
kanapali and and north of
so if you're looking North to your
destination
I want to describe this this is so
important it's a visual understanding
you have two shopping malls one on your
right one on your left the one on your
right as you're looking North is called
Lahaina Gateway that's where I'm going
to for the mayor's presser in just about
five minutes
um I have an hour drive but but on the
other side is called The Cannery that's
where the Safeway was where everybody
was in line and then to get it's not to
get out of these malls they don't have
multiple entrances and exits and the the
one the line of Gateway only has one in
and out which is just like
what so so you have these two malls side
by side you have your route of exit
which is called honora pilani Highway
had fallen power lights remember 29
energized power lines went down during
this sequence of the Fall Lahaina
falling so you have no good options in
some way you could go the bypass and the
police could send you around to go back
to what you could Kahului the main part
of Maui but then they're sending you to
where the fire was and where the fire
jumped we don't know if that's burned
out if the police send you up the
bypassing around they're sending people
um south on the highway if you're on the
other side of the fire sure that's
another whole evacuation scenario but
the Northbound evacuation scenario I
have determined you had no good options
you had the bypass you had forward
through the down power lines or you had
um keave Street which is the street that
leads to the bypass and goes towards the
water and yes I've confirmed with
several that that's where police were
sending people back towards Safeway down
keave street towards Front Street which
then added to the backup on Front Street
all the way into town and made Front
Street impassable but that's as police
were reluctant or unwilling or were
under the orders I do not know which one
to send people through the power lines
on the highway or to the fire on the
bypass
so again
these are incredibly difficult decisions
which you know hindsight the the person
I interviewed said yes hindsight is 2020
but uh there were three difficult routes
but but he did say I don't know why
you'd want to send people back to Front
Street the quickest route of egress was
the highway even if there were down
power lines people were still going and
they were getting through they were
braving it they knew that was their
quickest way out and as the fire became
more and more ominous and began to Bear
Down on Lahaina Town people did take
that Highway through the power lines
so what I get from this is the
town the way it was set up and the
climate and the environment made it uh
into a death trap and what unfolded was
the unfortunate consequence of the fact
that people were left with no good
option as you described on Front Street
no good options given the uh absence of
warning and preparation okay the last
thing I want to ask you and in some ways
it's the most important I know you from
prior stories that you've covered
including January 6th where you as a
reporter were actually in the capital
um
is it fair to say that if you had the
sense that what was going on here was
the result of premeditated
uh uh skullduggery of some kind I'd be
all over if that was the case I mean I'm
all over it and let me tell you I mean
to where I needed to go to tell the
story of the people of West Maui and
what they've gone through in the pain
The Suffering The the trauma that
they're dealing with I had to break away
in a in a very unconventional way we
were taking on a tour first of all the
I I was not very did not feel very
welcome on the Press Convoy even though
I'm local media
um there was in my opinion
um not uh uh I was not so welcome that
morning I feel
I ended up having to catch up to the
Convoy uh then it turned out I was in
front of the Convoy and then turned out
I had no good information from the
Convoy and the Convoy was passing me but
eventually I got into the governor's
Convoy and I drove uh Saturday morning
which is uh the it's Tuesday Wednesday
the day five the morning of no reporters
were on that side at that time and I I
did the walk through tour I tried to get
answers to the questions I felt that I
wasn't getting great answers I knew
there'd be several press conferences to
follow in which we'd get
mediocre if you know nonsensical answers
whatever it was I felt the story was
elsewhere it was with the people when we
were leaving Front Street we go through
the burnt out town and I mentioned keave
street that goes to one side of the
bypass and the other one is Street we go
up that street and then to the left is
the bypass that would take us back to
the other side the north side of Lahaina
the other is the road that would take us
up to Town the entire Convoy turns right
because I'm at the back and they had you
know initially tried to ditch me I feel
I'll explain that another time they I
was I was given suspect information
let's just put it that way of time and
meeting place and not a lot of effort to
Usher me in but I saw I see the Convoy
go and I turn left and that's it I knew
that the story was up in West Maui for
the last several days and I made it my
business to be the only reporter that
was there during that isolation to talk
to people and get the stories out and
you can find those stories which I've
published on my Instagram uh Jeremy
reporter
all right Jeremy Lee Quinn I know you
have to go I've got to go on your uh
your mission I really appreciate what
you've put into reporting this story and
I know that if the evidence shows up
that says there's some other explanation
that you will be all over it and I will
also be very interested in uh
broadcasting it and making sure people
hear it if that evidence exists but
until then people should be careful not
to over interpret what they've heard in
a disastrous situation because it would
in some ways be easier if there was a
villain I think so a cartoonish one in
the villain that that the the mistakes
and you know that people are unwilling
to look at and face up to is
um in is much more real and and tells a
much different and much more
um important story for leaders in ages
ahead to learn from I think
that's very well said all right Jeremy
good luck in Godspeed thank you